[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
the observers chief leader writer sonia
soda and also the times as home affairs
editor matt dathan hi to you both they
will both be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what is on
some of those front pages
and an angry liverpool echo responds to
the murder of nine-year-old olivia pratt
corbell and the news that the gunman and
his accomplices drove off without
helping her by asking the community
whose side are you on
the eye points out that olivia has
become the youngest ever person in the
uk to lose their life
to the violence of organized crime
the express calls her an innocent victim
of the gun wars
this is the front of the sun
gunned down at bedtime and left to die
the mirror sums up the story in one word
unbearable
the male describes its own image of
olivia as a picture of innocence to
shame lawless britain
the metro pleads tell us who killed
little olivia
the financial times leads with the chief
executive of scottish power telling
ministers that a rescue plan to protect
households from rising bills will need
funding of more than 100 billion pounds
over two years
while the telegraph reports that british
diplomats are trying to persuade
european governments to keep funding
support for the war in ukraine because
they may prefer to prioritize the cost
of living crisis
the guardian has word of massive profits
for the grain sector amid what it calls
an unjust hunger crisis
and on a much different note the star
has an apparent a story about the
apparent benefits of
well getting frisky
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us
and tonight we are joined by sonia soder
and matt dathan thank you both so much
uh for joining us this evening and as we
look through all of those front pages uh
one story dominating all of them it's
unusual isn't it so i need to see
one image of one person on pretty much
every single paper apart from the
financial times and that's not a
surprise given
you know it's it's it's bent um
absolutely desperate story random and
needless death
well it's the worst kind of uh tragic
story an innocent nine-year-old girl
shot dead um in liverpool um more
details have emerged during the day as a
result of the police appeals it sounds
like well we know what happened was that
um there was it you know the police
think it believe it was the result of an
organized crime fight
olivia's mother opened the door to see
what was going on outside the commotion
uh the person who was being pursued the
criminal who was being pursued by the
person who eventually killed olivia saw
a [ __ ] of light forced his way into
their house
olivia's mother got shot um
in the course of that and olivia was
fatally shot and later died and the
details of this are just i mean so awful
the um you know the person who was being
pursued his friends came and picked him
up and he kind of walked past um uh
olivia who was dying on the floor and
her mother who was with her and i just
think it's it's
you know it's just
such a tragedy and um you know that's
obviously why it's kind of on all the
front pages a totally uh senseless
killing and i think the liverpool echoes
front page it's you know it's very much
an appeal there are people who will know
um who killed olivia and who were the
people behind this and um you know this
is a plea from the police that is being
echoed by the liverpool echo that
whoever knows i mean they must come
forward and they must speak to the
police um because um you know that her
killers really do need to be brought to
justice
and
those images of her i mean just you know
just about to go into year five
at school sonia and and and
the the chief constable of merseyside
police serena kennedy saying that this
is not the time for anyone who knows
anything to stay tight-lipped
the utter horror of this story the hope
really is that that whatever was going
on that led to these events on the
streets that the criminal underworld in
liverpool
will
bring forward the person who did this
yes that's right and um you know it's
just
it's sort of so unthinkable i think to
think about um you know how this you
know this could have happened to anyone
you sort of open the door and the next
thing you know a scene is just playing
out that is you know your worst ever
nightmare involving your own child i
mean it's just i think parents around
the country aunts and uncles
grandparents around the country will be
just watching this with you know just in
horror really um and you know it is the
third
um it's the third fatality in liverpool
in a week that you know it's a third
shooting um sort of fatal shooting and
the police think that they that these
three killings may all be connected but
obviously this is this was of a
nine-year-old girl there's another
innocent victim a 28 year old woman who
was gunned down in her own home the
police think that that was a case of
mistaken identity and a 22 year old man
lost
his life and i think what you know in a
horrible echo of the past
this was 15 years to the day olivia's
killing to the day that reese jones a
boy in liverpool was killed as a result
of gang land killings um back in
liverpool 15 years ago so that's just
kind of like another horrible um twist
to this i think and let's bring in matt
and matt uh sonia was talking about
there you know it's easy to say that
these events are very rare and that we
shouldn't be concerned you know the
people that aren't involved in gangs and
in that kind of violence shouldn't be
concerned about their own safety but
three shootings in a week of people who
don't appear to have anything to do with
such things will certainly concern a
great many people especially in the
liverpool area
yeah that's right and what we've heard
across sky news and other programmes
today is it's from people uh in
liverpool across merseyside really quite
um scared about uh letting their own
kids and even their own well their own
family out of their own houses it's
quite a shocking incident that uh you
open your own door to see what's going
on in your own streets and your
your own nine-year-old daughter's shot
uh seconds later what i found really
interesting uh and really what comes the
heart of the liverpool echoes front page
is the police and throughout today the
police have been really appealing to the
hearts over the minds of a criminal of
the criminal community across liverpool
really appealing to them to to imagine
that it was their own nine-year-old
daughter their own nine-year-old sister
uh that nine-year-old okay my
nine-year-old granddaughter and and to
say look as this front page shows whose
side you're on you've got to put aside
your gang rivalries and help the police
find
uh the the killer and those responsible
and i think um we've also heard today
that uh the the real problem that we've
had in the past liverpool which has been
addressed in the last few years of this
real anti-grass culture that in
liverpool people staying silent and we
heard that after reece jones is killing
the killer was took ages to be brought
to justice i think it was a year and a
half it took until convicted
and there's a real danger and concern
among police
tonight
that anti-grass culture might prevent
them from finding the killer in this um
a tragedy as well
and yet of course there is the phrases
and their honor amongst thieves and
the fact that that police press
conference was really quite powerful it
was very very strongly worded and the
fact that there has been such public
outcry about this matt do you think that
it might change anything
uh well you've got to hope so haven't
you and
there are encouraging signs uh last few
years since reece jones is killing that
but there is more trust in the police
and and uh the more trust in police than
uh than staying silent and um
i think i mean my own personal instinct
is that when you see the the
heart-wrenching pictures of this um
nine-year-old girl and you read the
stories of how she was killed uh last
night so mercilessly around 10 p.m it's
opening the door you you really hope
that the vast majority of even criminals
would would help even anonymously uh
with a with a call to the police and if
not the police then possibly crime
stoppers
and um sonia you mentioned it a little
earlier that the extraordinary timing of
it being 15 years to the exact day
that that reese jones died and that was
a story that also really captured the
public imagination didn't it no there
was a real sense that action was taken
after that there were a lot of
organizations that were set up after
that i mean does this show that those
kind of organizations and those
initiatives have failed
well there's clearly been a failure in
the sense that you know this is going on
in liverpool today
and i think there's going to be a lot of
reflection i mean it shouldn't take the
death of a little nine-year-old girl to
sort of propel this issue to the front
pages and to propel a really kind of
serious national conversation but i
think it undoubtedly will now and i
think there will be a lot of reflection
on what's gone wrong in sort of you know
in recent years around um around
policing around um prevention of this
sort of gang violence um but really i
think the next there will be time for
that and um you know the next the next
decade will all be about trying to
establish what happened and trying to
bring um olivia's killers to justice i
think the other thing that makes me
difficult and you know it's very notable
that in what the police have said
they've tried to provide reassurances
that people coming forward can do so
anonymously that they will be protected
that they will be safe because there
will be i think some people who might
want to do the right thing but might
feel scared as well about
retaliation from from these gangs if
they come forward so i think those
assurances from the police are very very
important indeed
and and final thoughts on on this matter
you know we've talked about the person
that did the killing but but the fact
that that the man who was running away
stepped over
olivia as he as he left the house and
her mother was screaming for help we
understand but of course people on the
street
were too scared to come out of their
houses and and rightly so given you know
what they had just heard
um the police making it really clear
that they want everybody involved in
this attack to be brought to justice
absolutely and that includes the 35 year
old man who burst into the
uh to the house last night a
quote that's particularly stuck out for
me in the metro from the assistant chief
constable there
quoting howard individual does not
deserve to be walking the streets um and
i think what really struck me as really
quite a tragic thought was the 35 man
who was shot in the chest several times
one of his uh friends um uh drove his um
a black audi to pick him up uh to take
him to hospital but left nine-year-old
olivia and her mum cheryl who was also
shot as well in the arm
left them on the doorstep and they had
to wait for the ambulance and who knows
whether they might olivia might have
lived if that
if that man had taken them to hospital
in his um car as well
it's just gruesome on every and every
level isn't it um sonia and matt thank
you both very much for talking that
through with us uh coming up though
after the break stark warnings from the
head of scottish power as to how much
government money it may take to keep
households afloat you stay with us
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now sonia soda and matt
dathan taking us through tomorrow's
front pages and some of the inside pages
as well um sonya let's move on to the
financial times now and away from the
dreadful story up in liverpool um and
this is about the cost of living uh the
cost of shielding families
from this fuel bill shock
reckoning to cost as much as a hundred
billion pounds uh according to the ft uh
it's called it's from one of the uh
largest uh energy groups scottish power
isn't it
that's right so um the boss of scottish
power is estimating that if the
government were to freeze energy bills
the energy price cap where it is at the
moment for two years that would cost a
hundred billion pounds over two years
now that's obviously something similar
along the lines of what the opposition
labor have said they would do if they
were in government um it's a huge amount
of money just to put it in context um
the total value of the coronavirus
furlough package that supported people
um who uh to ensure that people didn't
get laid off
during the block downs and that cost 69
billion pounds but it really is that
scale of support that we're talking
about that families need i mean this is
a financial emergency on the same scale
or perhaps even worse in the the covert
pandemic and we've got a conservative
leadership race where actually neither
of the candidates are sort of saying
firmly what they would do if they were
prime minister even though the next
massive hike in energy bills is only a
few weeks off it's coming in october
so i think you know this is it's very
sobering
and it really should provide food for
thought you know we've got blizz trust
who is almost certain to be the next
prime minister and she's not committing
to any action yet i just personally
don't think that that's that's good
enough there were obviously questions to
be um about how this support should be
channeled to families is the best thing
to freeze the energy price cap is it to
um target very significant cash payments
at um you know the lowest income
families there are questions about the
exact mechanism but i think there is
absolutely no question that a package of
this kind of scale is needed and it's
something we're going to see eventually
i think from the next prime minister so
why aren't they talking about it now
yeah
and matt you know liz trust is now not
talking about an awesome statement she's
talking about a fiscal event
but you know any confidence that
anything will actually happen as soon as
we do get a new prime minister whoever
it may be
well i think there is actually uh
increasing confidence that there will be
that emergency help or some form of
emergency help that
actually perhaps at the start of the
contest was trying to play down
expectations the ft the financial times
from paige
reports that there the music in
government is shifting and let's
remember that the current business
secretary kwazii koten is uh tipped to
be the next chancellor and he's met with
the chief executive of scottish power um
over these plans
but i think the details of how it's
going to be paid off
will probably appall liz truss's
principles uh or at least the principles
that she's been uh touting during the
leadership contest because um the
proposals um suggest paying it off
by either general taxation over the next
10 to 15
years
or a rise in bills spread over the next
10 to 15 years now
given that liz truss is selling herself
as the true tax cutting conservative i
can't imagine her
coming to number 10 and one of our first
big decisions is to sign up to a plan
that will require 15 years worth of
taxation but who knows and given the
scale of the crisis and we'll we'll see
that on friday with the cap expected to
rise to 3200 from october that's the
decision is going to be on friday um
the scale of the crisis might require
this trust to perhaps dump in some of
her core principles yeah
okay uh final front page which we
haven't really got time to talk about
but i think it's just worth looking at
uh quite striking front page city am
london's business newspaper uh there it
is bad news pages two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven good
news
page one crosswell to fully open in
november it means a lot to those in the
city of london doesn't it that you'll be
able to get from east to west
relatively quickly but uh good to see
their take on that news today